[Music]
on this tuesday night hospitals on alert
for the more contagious and more
dangerous
variants more people are going to suffer
and die from the illness
fresh warnings of a compounding crisis
updated guidelines on who should get
vaccinated next
who's being bumped up in the queue plus
the new delivery delay
critics take aim at ottawa's new offer
to buy back
banned weapons i feel betrayed the bill
triggering
many questions and from a snow nato
to treacherous conditions the bone
chilling blast of winter leaving texans
powerless
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a slow burn of variants
across this country the number of new
cases of covid19
is dropping right now but there is
growing evidence highly contagious new
variants
are picking up steam there are now more
than 570 confirmed cases of variance of
concern
across all 10 provinces the true number
is likely higher since genomic
sequencing is needed to confirm the
cases
most involve the variant first detected
in the uk but
the south african and brazilian variants
are also here
these variants have been smoldering in
the background
and gaining fuel that now threatens to
flare up into a new rapidly spreading
blaze
public health experts warn not to become
complacent and
that it is too risky to begin easing
public health restrictions now
yet some provinces are doing just that
ontario lifted its stay-at-home order
for much of the province today and
reopened schools in the hardest hit
regions
alberta and manitoba have also eased
some restrictions allowing
gyms and restaurants to reopen with
limited capacity
saskatchewan today extended its public
health measures
for at least four more weeks all the
virus needs to spread is for people to
come into contact with each other
we know the variants of concern are much
more contagious
and now there is some evidence from the
uk the variant first identified there
has an increased risk of hospitalization
and death
heather urix west has our top story
tonight
students in toronto trudged through the
snow to get to their first in-person
classes of 2021.
schools reopened in toronto peel and
york this week
after an extended closure in order to
control the spread of kovitt 19.
but with variance of concern in the
community some on the front lines fear
the reopening
is coming too soon in ontario what we're
doing is simultaneous school reopening
and economic reopening
while these variants grab a foothold in
our community and to me to do those
things at the same time doesn't make any
sense
the variant that first emerged in the uk
has been detected in all
10 provinces with evidence of community
spread
in four the rapid rise of cases in a
previously well-controlled situation in
newfoundland and labrador
is a testament to how quickly things can
change
when more contagious variants are
introduced that province has now linked
nearly 300 cases with the b-117 variant
its ability to spread more easily from
person to person remains a concern
but now there is also growing evidence
to suggest this variant could be more
dangerous as well a document posted by
british government scientists
friday examines a series of recent
studies on the variant that first
emerged in the uk
based on these analyses it reads it is
likely that infection with variant of
concern b117
is associated with an increased risk of
hospitalization and death
compared to infection with non-voc
viruses
and that risk would be somewhere around
1.3 for every three people that get
hospitalized or die
with the usual type of cova-19 then
four are going to be hospitalized or die
with the new variant recent modeling in
ontario and
alberta has shown that without new
restrictions the b117 variant could
become a dominant strain
in just weeks leaving hospitals to brace
for an impact that could be more severe
than anything canada has seen before
heather urex west global news
calgary the variants of concern are more
transmissible
less responsive to vaccines and make
reinfection more common
here is how they evolved the first
genetic sequence of the novel
coronavirus came from a sample
taken from a worker in the seafood
market in wuhan china
that seed has grown branching out into a
family tree
the more people a virus infects the more
it replicates
over time genetic changes occur creating
new branches known as variants
most variants are of little concern but
three
possibly more have emerged with
advantages allowing them to
thrive and outrun others first detected
in the uk
south africa and brazil what makes them
extraordinary are the number of
mutations they've acquired
at once these three possess the n501y
mutation it affects the all-important
spike protein
the key that opens the way into healthy
human cells
making these variants is believed up to
50 percent
more contagious canada's top doctor says
the public health agency is still
examining what impact the variants might
have on vaccines
canada's sluggish vaccine rollout is
supposed to pick up speed this week
though today there was another setback
bad weather
here's mike lacatura next week
we're expecting an even larger shipment
from pfizer again
prime minister justin trudeau is
doubling down on his promise to have 6
million doses of covet 19 vaccines in
canada
by the end of march that's despite bad
weather
causing a one day delay to the pfizer
shipment
vaccine makers like moderna promise
orders
will be filled he confirmed that as
promised
we are on track to receive two million
doses of the moderna vaccine before the
end of march
that's in addition to the three million
doses of the pfizer buy in tech vaccine
expected in the next seven weeks
still just 1.7 percent of canadians have
gotten a shot
far fewer than many of our allies on the
weekend the united kingdom announced
that it had vaccinated
15 million people in 60 days the united
states
has vaccinated over 54 million people
i'd much rather be in canada given the
number of deaths and cases in the u.s in
the uk
over the last year dr alan bernstein is
part of canada's covit 19 vaccine task
force
he says canada is vaccinating at the
same rate as countries like the
netherlands
his big worry the more infectious and
more serious
variants well the combination of those
two things
means it's bad news and so the sooner we
vaccinate people
the sooner we'll have fewer people
walking around with virus
that's why the focus will soon be on the
provinces and how
quickly they can get needles in arms
will the prime minister
start showing leadership ndp leader
jagmeet singh wants to call in the
military to help with the rollout
but the country's top doctor says human
resources
isn't the issue we have many pharmacists
family doctors
you know other other health
professionals retired
they're all volunteering so we've got
the volunteers we just need more
vaccines
pfizer is saying it's possible its
michigan plant could start supplying
canada
later this year likely speeding up the
entire process but
a company spokesperson said for now
canada will continue to get doses from
the facility
in belgium mike lacrouter global news
ottawa
though the majority of canadians are
still waiting to be vaccinated there are
new recommendations about who should be
given priority in the second
phase racialized communities
disproportionately affected by covid19
are among them eric sorenson explains
why and
what phase of the rollout you fall into
as vaccines are ramping up more
canadians will be lining up
the national advisory committee on
immunization is prioritizing who
in turn should be vaccinated stage one
underway now
includes residents and staff of
congregant seniors care homes
those over aged 80 followed by those
over 75 and then over 70
front line health care and personal
support workers in contact with covid
patients
and adults in indigenous communities
most at risk
a large percentage from stage one should
receive first shots from the six
million doses expected to arrive by the
end of march
stage two includes indigenous
communities not covered in stage one
residents and staff of other congregate
living settings
including group homes all those aged
60-69
first responders police and firefighters
essential workers who can't work
virtually or from home
and adults in racialized and
marginalized communities
disproportionately affected by covet 19.
that's a new priority group the approach
is based on
saving lives first and then protecting
people that are
working close to folks that are at risk
of contracting coped
a recent summary found racialized people
in toronto
accounted for 79 percent of kovit 19
cases
when they only make up about half the
actual population
but one expert says the priority should
be on jobs that are high exposure
not on race which could touch off
resentment these
essential workers where a lot of them
are racialized
the job really puts them at risk and if
you have that as a criteria rather than
the race because you can have white
people working in fast food restaurants
or
in grocery stores as well if as promised
millions more vaccines arrive this
spring
those in stage two could start to be
vaccinated in the second quarter
stage three includes adults aged 50 to
59
and those 16 to 59 with underlying
medical conditions
plus non-front-line health care and
essential workers
these are guidelines specific priority
groups will be determined by the
provinces
with covid numbers coming down and
vaccines going up
the outlook is improving but there
remains an x factor
the covid variants make the course of
the pandemic still uncertain
eric sorensen global news toronto
the families of people who died in
horrific conditions at a montreal
long-term care home will have to wait
several more months for a public inquiry
the coroner leading proceedings into
covert related deaths in quebec's
long-term care homes has
agreed to delay the hearing of the heron
residents until
september 47 people died there last
spring
testimony was set to begin yesterday the
care home's owners asked for a delay
until prosecutors decide whether to lay
criminal charges
the coroner says the inquiry into other
quebec facilities will proceed
next month nine months after it was
promised the federal government has laid
out new
gun control legislation it includes a
buy-back program for banned assault
style weapons and
allowing municipalities and cities to
ban handguns
but beyond those broad strokes there is
very little detail
as mercedes stevenson reports that
includes how much
it will all cost the tableau
in ottawa of the prime minister joined
by key members of cabinet
sets a scene that underscores the
political importance of the gun control
message for the liberal government
but let's not forget what this is about
saving lives following through on a
campaign promise trudeau announced a new
bill with a range of measures
the bill promises a gun buyback program
tougher penalties for smuggling or
trafficking guns
makes it easier for police to seize them
and will allow
cities to ban handguns the buy-back
program will be optional
not mandatory while the guns are illegal
some will still be out there i feel
betrayed
something gun control advocates say guts
the legislation
the only way we could have really
changed
the picture in canada would be
to have a mandatory buy back to have
something
permanent and to have a permanent impact
block quebecois
won't support the bill due to the
optional buyback which he says
makes the
the position the law under many regards
useless the government estimates there
are between 100 and 200
000 now prohibited firearms in canada
but officials don't know much about them
we actually had no information and have
no information about who owns them
and where they're located or even what
makes and models
are out there there was also no official
estimate of how much legal gun owners
will be compensated
or what the program will cost but public
safety minister bill blair
spitballed three to four million if the
government pays an average of thirteen
hundred dollars per gun
the canadian sport shooting association
says that's a vast underestimate
we're looking at probably in business
inventory in canada somewhere between
three and five
billion dollars of inventory in canada
conservative leader aaron o'toole
accused the government of targeting the
wrong people
and questioned how the measures will
stop illegal guns like the ones used in
the nova scotia massacre
from entering canada mr trudeau misleads
people when he tries to suggest that
that buying things back from hunters and
other canadians who are
law abiding is somehow going to solve
the problem of
of shooting and criminal gang activity
why the federal government is leaving it
to cities to ban handguns when they are
the number one firearm
used in homicides in this country is
unclear
donna mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks
the mayhem the mess and the misery in
texas coming up
the snowstorm that slammed into the lone
star state
in amsterdam they are skating on thin
ice this group was pulled from
amsterdam's canals on the weekend after
they
fell through the ice it is cold but not
cold enough to solidly freeze the canals
the skaters struggled to get out and
were rescued with the help of ropes
and hockey sticks dutch officials have
urged people to avoid risky skating
because the hospitals dealing with
covid19 patients
certainly don't need the extra burden
people in southern ontario had to wade
through heavy snow
this morning after a powerful storm hit
some school boards in the greater
toronto area had to postpone the return
to in-person classes today toronto
district schools were open though buses
were not running
in whitby two children were trapped in
snow pushed by a plow police say
one was taken to hospital with serious
injuries the other has minor
injuries and much of the us is enduring
a brutal blast of winter from the great
lakes all the way down to the gulf coast
the storm is putting lives at risk
cities in the south and the midwest have
reached record low temperatures
texans though are bearing the brunt of
it as jackson proskow reports
millions of texans are in the dark
the record-setting cold in texas might
be bearable
if people still had heat and power the
thing is there's no
end in sight right now more than four
million customers woke up to a second
day without electricity
left to warm up in their cars or by the
fire
after the state's electricity grid
buckled under demand
fueled by the bitter cold this morning
when i called they told me
10 a.m but i called back after 10 a.m
and they said that they were just
working on it so
i don't there was no update in fort
worth residents are under a boil water
order after the water treatment plant
lost power
the blackout threatened to spoil
thousands of doses of covet 19 vaccine
which needs to be kept ultra cold
leading to a surprise rush to offer them
up to the public
before they expired i literally dropped
everything got everything on
and sprinted here and apparently
everyone else had the
same thought as me in dallas the
temperature dropped to minus
18 degrees overnight the city rarely
sees temperatures below freezing
in houston some simply tried to make the
most of it when you live in houston you
don't really have
regular sleds the unprecedented winter
storms spun up a rare snow nado
and put the entire state of texas under
winter storm warnings
the weather system responsible impacts a
wide swath of the u.s
120 million americans are left to face
everything from snow
to freezing rain to bitter cold to
deadly tornadoes
at least three people were killed
overnight in north carolina
after their homes were flattened by a
rare february twister
i've seen devastation that i have not
seen in many years
it's truly truly was a disaster last
night
back in texas the winter woes aren't
over yet
another storm is set to move in on
wednesday this one bringing freezing
rain
the millions already in the dark have
been warned the power
may not come back on for days jackson
prosko global news
the rise of another virus ahead the
disease making a deadly comeback in west
africa
the value of bitcoin rose sharply and
hit a new high today a sign major
companies could be warming up to
cryptocurrencies
at one point the digital coin surpassed
fifty thousand dollars u.s
a year ago the cost of a single unit
hovered around ten thousand dollars
bitcoin's value has been on the rise as
more mainstream companies like tesla say
they will accept it
as a form of payment viruses don't care
that we're already in a pandemic and
right now another one is making a
resurgence in west africa
ebola guinea has declared an outbreak
and today the who put six neighboring
countries on alert
five people in guinea have died from the
viral illness
the democratic republic of congo has
also reported three fatal cases
although there is no indication the
outbreaks are linked the ebola virus has
ravaged both countries before
the largest ebola outbreak in history
began in guinea in 2013
more than 11 000 people died in three
countries
before the epidemic was declared over in
2016.
pandemic puzzle next why is india's
covid case count plummeting
you're watching global national
something is going on in india that is
perplexing medical experts
cases of kobit 19 are plummeting and no
one is exactly sure why
vaccinations have been ruled out because
they only began in january
redmond shannon looks at what's
happening
by last september new coven 19 cases in
india hit
100 000 a day with fears the spread
would only
get worse but as the second wave took
off in the west
india saw a steady drop off in cases for
five months
and counting i come to think about this
one nightmare
i'm never going to live now this new
delhi couple is relieved that as their
symptoms subside
so too has the spread the worst is
definitely over
and it's just a matter of time before i
think
total normal life will restart so has
india unlocked
some covert 19 secret we have actually
now entered a much safer zone however
the danger still lurks around the corner
the transmission has come down
partly because the susceptibles
are either already exposed or are better
protected
already exposed sounds a lot like herd
immunity
studies have shown a majority of some
city residents
have already had the virus usually
without symptoms
when you look at india you have to look
at a hundred sub epidemics
not just one big one herd immunity
implies
some kind of a permanent resistance
against the virus and we don't see
evidence of that
the concern is that if most people have
had mild infections
they won't be immune especially against
new variants
any suggestions that while india's
turned the corner
and everything is going to be rosy from
this point on is quite naive
all you have to do is to look at
the amazonis area in brazil there it was
thought
three quarters of people had been
infected but the new variant that
emerged in brazil has again
crippled the health care system if india
can harness the power of its
huge vaccine-making industry before new
variants take hold
it might just get ahead of its own
second wave
redmond shannon global news london
and that's global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen just because
we can't go to mardi gras in new orleans
doesn't mean we can't give you just a
little glimpse of what it's like this
year
they're calling it yardy graw this year
over 5 000 homes and porches have been
turned into what look like parade floats
there's a virtual map and people drive
along the route
there are even a few canadian tributes
to shit's creek and
alex trebek a pandemic can't stop a
party
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
bye-bye
you